I am extremely pleased to have this
panel here it's it represents an
incredibly diverse group of viewpoints
and and interest and I look forward to
the dialogue that we're going to have
together i will also at last 10 minutes
of the panel open it up to audience
questions and answers so I will I will
you know stop our own discussion before
before the end of the panel let me
briefly introduce our panelists and the
game plan is to have our panelists each
star with about five to seven minutes
worth of opening remarks one of these
that's terrific about this group is that
they represent a real wide array of
interests and experiences immediately to
my left is Steve Fraden who's the vice
chairman of pershing square capital
management where he has been for the
last two years that right six six six
months okay time flies or doesn't I met
I've known Steve for over a dozen years
back when he was at freed Frank before
he went to kirkland & ellis and is a
very very well known and respected M&A
attorney and his a real fixture
nationally high he represents represents
boards committees in Special
Investigations in the M&A corporate
governance context and and we're welcome
to welcome Steve to his left is Cal
Goldberg was a partner at Finsbury where
he advises management's management
boards and and an executives on their
communication strategy lately I guess in
large context in the in in the situation
involving proxy contests he was
previously a senior manager and director
in fti consulting strategic
communication segments and founded that
group special situations practice prior
to ft I mr. Goldberg help revision
positions at the Avalon group and hill
and knowlton so welcome cow and then
finally to to Cal's left is alan murray
who is the editor of fortune he's
responsible for overseeing fortune
magazine and fortune com with combined
audience of more than 13 million readers
I wish that were the case for my
academic papers but let's it goes it's
actually 17 million
out okay a dated document clearly so I
met Alan a few years ago when he was
with the wall street journal but he has
had a host of different of different
activities both on CSP CNBC Wall Street
Journal and now with Fortune and and
welcome Alan so let me let me just start
and maybe maybe I can take this in the
same order that I that i introduced the
speakers Stevie you have you have you
know worked this angle both as an
attorney in outside counsel and also now
inside a hedge fund and give me a give
me a sense of how from your perspective
media plays an important role in some of
your activities right so first thank you
very much for inviting me here I'm
delighted to be here I have to admit
that when i first met professor tally he
was then a brilliant young professor at
USC law school and somehow he has
managed to continue to be a brigand
young professor although now at columbia
law school so it's great to see you
again i feel so young so i think i think
the media has had an increasing impact
on in the corporate control area the
that was certainly evident when i was in
private practice at kirkland & ellis and
and before that it at freed Frank so in
organizing a team on any corporate
control transaction whether it's an M&A
deal or a proxy contest it was always
essential to bring in a sophisticated
financial public relations firm that was
not true I would say 20 years ago and
I'm one of the few people who survived
and who was doing M&A 20 years ago and
thirty years ago etc that was not
necessarily true a long time ago but
it's become absolutely essential now and
the reason for it is that
the media play a significantly bigger
role in corporate control transactions
one of the reasons for that I would
suggest is that corporate control
transactions have really changed in the
last 30 years so back in 1985 the
Delaware Supreme Court which decided the
Moran case which made poison pills
legitimate and subsequent case laws made
it clear that poison pills are entirely
legitimate and the effect of that and
i'm going to overstate only very
slightly is that it is absolutely
impossible to do hostile takeover
battles so if you can't do hostile
takeover battles and if the capital
markets believe and they do that
managers need to be monitored there's
only one device left for monitoring
corporate managers and that device is
proxy contests proxy contests involve
elections although they typically are
better run than the Republican primary
but they do involve elections and the
role of the media is is incredibly
significant their seat before I go on
before I move down the line to Cal what
one of the things that's interesting
about the legal evolution in this area
and I agree with you that that over the
last 20 to 30 years the idea that some
hostile tender offer is going to
transfer control it's it's now a sort of
a pipe dream it's a fable from years
pass and possibly and so now this is
really just a question about how do you
how do you contest an election in a you
know in a way that's going to be
effective or defend if you were sitting
on management side and and I want to get
a sense also from you that you know we
had for instance a case involving
Sotheby's just a year and a half ago in
which you know Sotheby's devised a
poison pill that was actually a poison
pill that was geared around activism as
opposed to the hostile takeover where
there were two thresholds which the
poison pill took place that it seems to
me that we may be in a moment
now we're Delaware law to be sure is now
starting to try to try to grapple with
some of these defensive measures in the
context of activism as opposed to the
context of hostile bid how do you see
this playing out over the next couple of
years so I I don't see the courts
playing as big a role dealing with
shareholder activism and dealing with
elections and I don't see them playing
as big a role there as they did in the
M&A context because when the courts
decided that they were going to let
boards adopt structural defenses that
would be able to keep the company
independent unless the board decided to
sell the company i think that was done
cautiously with a view that they were
going to permit shareholders of the
franchise to have the ability to vote
the directors out of office if the
shareholders disagreed with what the
board was doing and so I expect the
Delaware courts although they're not
friendly to activists it's quite clear
and if you listen to Chief Justice
Strine speak and if you read sort of
between the lines and some of the
opinions it's quite clear then not very
friendly to activists but I don't
believe that they're going to permit
courts to adopt in effect structural
defenses to proxy contests and indeed
just last year I was involved in the
valiant Pershing Square bid for allergan
and Vice Chancellor Bouchard presented
with the opportunity to enforce by laws
that have been adopted by allergan that
were extraordinarily oppressive and
would have made it impossible to call a
special meeting basically told allegan
that he was not going to enforce it and
they better act more sensibly and modify
the bylaws to permit Pershing Square and
valiant to call the special meeting
interesting vote full disclosure I was
an expert on the other side of that case
but we can talk about that later Cal let
me let me transition over to you one of
the things that's been very interesting
about
about the last year or two in in
corporate governance is not only the
advent of the high-profile proxy contest
that DuPont the Sotheby's that's played
out you know as much in the in the in
you know in press releases and in the
public arena but also a sense that I
think a lot of people have if you go to
back to the 2015 proxy season you know
shareholder proposals hardly ever win
but there's one brand of shareholder
proposal that's been winning a lot
lately which is proxy access shareholder
proposals I think a lot of people feel
that you know this wave is probably
going to continue in 2016 it's going to
open up maybe even more of these of
these proxy contests in the future
suppose that you know you're contacted
either by you know an activist
shareholder or a board trying to figure
out how they get their message out what
what are some of the top things that
you're going to advise the right off of
the bat sure well I guess maybe it's a
couple things in terms of I guess a
couple of thoughts on the environment
for all this playing off of what Steve
was talking about in terms of the
difference between how you handle the
communications pieces of this from a
super hostile bid standpoint versus more
of a proxy fight perspective I think one
of the reasons that the media relations
aspects of these contests has gotten
sort of evolved is because just
generally I think on the proxy contests
you've just got more convincing to do of
more people in the sense that it's not
just trying to convince the portfolio
managers on just the pure business case
the people voting are going to be the
governance folks within those those
institutions and they're just paying
attention to a much broader array of
issues and that's where having a good
media plan having the media if not on
your side then at least covering things
in a balanced manner that's where it
really helps you so I think there's
disturb this one point about kind of why
it's important more from a proxy
perspective I think the second thing
it's just a couple things on the media
environment and I'm sure Allen will have
a reaction to these one way or another
but I think in terms of just the way
that these corporate and financial
situations have gotten covered of late
it's it's changed quite a bit in the
sense that you know whether it's a deal
or a proxy situation or or a management
change what you're seeing is that the
coverage cycle on all these things has
gotten much more quick and buy more
quick I mean the thread stories that use
used to see play out over a week or two
or a month timeframe across these
episodes are now all coming out really
in the same day so for example you have
a leak of a possible deal between Dao in
dupont and today you're seeing stories
all the way talking about whether
they're going to get they're going to
get any trust approval you have a you
have an activist maker making a comment
and filing the 13 d and two hours later
you have thread stories about who the
next CEO the company could be and
nothing's happened yet so i think the
coverage cycle of this all this stuff
have just gotten so accelerated that
it's very difficult to manage it and i
think that's what's one thing that's
creating the sort of this media
sensitivity can i interject yeah a
couple of points in terms of proxy
contests one of the factors that I
always have thought was very important
when I was representing the company was
that you wanted the morale of the board
to remain high and public relations has
a major impact even if good PR is not
going to help you get votes it may help
keep the board unified so I think that's
important the second- the second thing
that I always used to try to stay away
from and it's not always possible but it
was a worthy effort is I didn't want to
burn bridges so most proxy contests
statistically end up getting settled and
if you've been out there calling the
insurgent director is a bunch of crooked
dopes it's going to be really hard even
from a fiduciary standpoint to put any
of those people on the board of
directors by the same token if you're
the activists and you've written a
series of intemperate letters to the to
the chairman of the board of the company
it's not going to be comfortable for you
to go into that boardroom after the
settlement so I try to always tried to
keep that down and and I think a good
public relations firm is helpful in that
too now let me push you a little bit
more on there something too to the
extent that that the proxy contest
setting which clearly is where we're
finding ourselves more more frequently
now is a little bit of an open season
Wild West hard to predict you've got
multiple people on the board you have
executives your job is essentially to
try to figure out how to manage the
message if you're working on the on the
on the target side company perspective
how do you go about doing that how do
you go about you know trying to figure
out with you know through whom where we
get a channel information a lot of these
directors are not but on a usual basis
on a daily basis they're not the
spokespeople generally for these
companies yeah that's right I think you
know the use of directors I think in a
front-facing standpoint I think on any
of his issues it's pretty episodic you
can sort of start there i mean you
generally see directors be more front
facing in the media when there's some
sort of special situation going on ie a
proxy contest or or there's a succession
plan in place or there's something
happening where it kind of their sort of
their to be kind of provide extra
support to the management team I think
what we talked to companies about is how
do you balance an important piece of
this which is there is a trade-off here
between using directors in these
situations in a front-facing way with
the perceived credibility and stability
of the management teams that are running
the company and it's it's it's it's not
easy because you you know the more you
have directors out there front facing
the more you kind of you start to not
necessarily a road but you sort of you
create this vibe that it's not just a
management team running the company and
so part of what you deal with on this
you know to your questionnaire a
connoisseur of getting ready for the
upcoming they're coming seizing is you
you need to really be selective on the
topics that sugar
have a director be out speaking about
succession is one that's always good
there's there's there others but i think
you know you need to you know companies
need to be careful that they're using
these folks judiciously from a stability
perspective and a governance perspective
interesting so Alan the the main line
media and then and we'll talk a little
bit about you know online media or
alternative media you know part of your
mandate is to you know convey the truth
convey the nature of these debates if it
is and I sort of agree with Cal here
that if the nature of these debates has
become much more fast-paced much more
prone to fulminations on either side how
do you go about yeah you're not just
reporting the facts you're part of the
story as well yes so so let me first of
all let me say that that Cal and Steve
are both much more expert at these proxy
contests than I am so I my observations
may come from a bit more of a 10,000
foot level but let me make four
observations that I think are very
relevant here first of all these days
when somebody starts talking to me about
the media I have no idea what they mean
I mean we live in an age where every
person in this room every person who
works for your company every investor
has access to publishing platforms that
if you do it right can reach millions of
people so we are all the media it is a
wide open world and that has
dramatically changed not just the
battles for control but the way
corporations run I mean I think you know
I were I can remember some very good
conversations you and I had about your
days at GM back in the day when the big
corporations were basically information
hierarchies information moved up and the
only person who had access to all the
information was the CEO and he became
the bottleneck for information to go to
the board well that's not the way the
world works now everybody has all the
information very quickly because you
know the the workers can reach out to
the board they can reach out to the
investors the investors can reach out to
everyone and so and
so it's a very very noisy media market
and while those of us in the mainstream
press or whatever you would want to call
it would like to think of us as being
extremely powerful the truth is the
power has dispersed so that's that's the
first point the second point is the one
that Cal alluded to I mean if you look
at what the transition that we are going
through at fortune magazine right now
I've only been there 14 months but I
have a group of reporters who come from
the magazine side who were accustomed to
in many cases writing once every two
months you know they would dive in they
talked to a whole bunch of people they'd
gather all their facts and they'd put
together a story and it would publish in
the magazine most of my reporters now
right at least twice a day some of them
may write four times a day or five times
a day so you don't have to do too much
analysis on those numbers to recognize
what a difference that is they're not
making 20 calls before they write their
stories they may be making one they may
not be making any calls at all they may
just be taking the available information
and and and putting together a story on
it now we're trying to develop reporters
who at least have enough expertise in
the areas they write about that they can
be fairly intelligent in the way they
assemble the information available at
any given moment but you know you go out
there and look at what's going on in
Business Insider or a lot of the people
who were competing against it is the
wild wild west so you're dealing with
people who have to respond very quickly
to what information whatever information
is available and that changes the nature
of the communication enormously the
third point I make that's more relevant
directly to these battles for corporate
control is that when you're dealing with
an activist investor it's a very
asymmetric information battle I mean
Bill Ackman can go on CNBC in five
minutes time
BAM and the companies have governance
and regulatory restrictions as well as
just bureaucratic clumsiness that make
that very very very difficult not tall
handsome young brilliant and charismatic
well well these guys are some of these
guys are pretty good at the media and
certainly Ackman's a good example that I
think dan loeb I can tell you from
personal experience the these guys work
the media with a sophistic
sophistication is not even the right
word it's a with a force that is
frightening I I was talking to somebody
and compared it to the days when I was
in Washington and had to deal with the
old Fannie Mae I mean it's a powerhouse
media operations that really play
hardcore games I mean I'll throw out one
example and I want to make sure I put
the proper qualifications on this but
there's been a series of stories in the
that have run on Reuters about Andrew
Liveris either or either of you involved
with dal really tough stories about
Andrew Liveris use of corporate money
for personal expenses and I think the
events that are in the stories happen
for four or five years ago now I have no
idea if this is true or not but I know
the folks at Dow are absolutely
convinced that the genesis of that
series of investigative stories is
download and if they're right it sort of
gets the Steve's point which is they
probably were put into motion before the
settlement was reached and one thing to
keep in mind is once the settlement is
reached you can't pull it you can't call
off the dogs once the journalists dogs
are out there they're going to they're
going to keep going so so I I do think
it is and it is an asymmetric battle
when it comes to dealing with the media
so given those three things I guess my
fourth and final point is how do you if
you're
corporation how do you deal with it well
I'm pretty certain that the way you
cannot deal with it is to say oh we're
going to tightly control information
because you aren't you will first of all
you'll be outgunned by that your
opponents who were playing a public game
and second you can't control the
information because of the the kind of
wide open social media environment I
described early now it was interesting
we early on in the DuPont battle we went
to dupont and said look we believe that
these are asymmetrical battles i can
tell you there's going to be a lot of
information comes from Ackman why don't
you open up and talk to us else pellets
excuse me you're right Nelson Peltz I'm
sorry also tall also and pretty good at
medium medium excuse me so you Nelson
you know Nelson Peltz is coming after
you they're going to be all over over
the media they have type very close
relationships with the media you should
open up and and let us in and spend some
time with us so we understand it and
they were unusual in the sense that they
did and the other thing that I think and
see if you may know better than I do
that was unusual about that situation
was the directors got involved to a
degree that I'm not I haven't seen in
the past you may have seen probably less
dealing with the media than dealing with
the investors but I think a decision was
made that we have to open this process
up that did help them win the battle but
Alan Coleman lost the war so you can
take what lessons from that that you
choose to take but I do think it's a
sign of a change in the in the way you
have to deal with these things it is
going to be a wide open battle whether
you want it to be or not just to play
off to just play off that one or two of
Alan's points I think one the biggest
part of crafting the communication
strategy on any of these things is
actually the forward scenario plan for
what happens after things go public
because you're going to have to respond
so quickly that you know we used to work
with companies and
you roll out a deal or you roll out some
Margaret you're making on a process
situation and you that's a sort of a day
to get that out there in the marketplace
and now you can't do it that way because
Alan has too many people writing too
many times a day and so we spent an
awful lot of time with clients in the
throes of battle where you're literally
I mean and it sounds like you know it
there's no other way to do it you spend
a lot of time course correcting directly
with reporters in a way that we didn't
before because the stories fly so
quickly that you know you end up you lay
out your scenario plan you things go
live or something comes out and you know
what the four or five things you're
going to have to say are in advance if
certain things happen and on top of that
you're chasing Corrections a lot of the
way or you're chasing amplifications
where you're chasing some change in the
way something you're trying to change
the way something is characterizing the
story so I think what's really changed
it's just yours we spent an awful lot
time course correcting after things go
live no way that I don't think we did
before well let me just follow on one
thing Alan and then I want to bring
Steve into this so a particularly unique
role I think fortune plays a couple
other you know large venerated media
outlets plays that not only are you you
know charged with trying to try to you
bring these facts up as a channel but
you want some level are also in
adjudicating some of those facts and in
at least that an editorial with right i
mean look I'll be honest that there are
very few publications that I will snip
pieces up and put up in front of my
corporations class where I am Miami a
class as proof as providing sort of a
balanced account of what's going on
fortune is one of those sources that I
will use and so what special goes you
know is there anything special that goes
into that I mean it may give you more
access as well right yeah well it's a
question of standards I mean part of the
if you go to the first point I made
about we're all publishers now that
means that there are no standards across
publishers you got people doing all
sorts of things we believe at the end of
the day fortune will survive because P
will recognize that we do have standards
and that we do have rules that we're
going to follow and so if you read
something unfortunate you can you can
trust it you can assume that we have
have confirmed it doesn't mean we don't
make mistakes we do make mistakes but we
have we have certain standards of
reporting I mean I had a kind of an
eye-opening experience I guess this was
three or four years ago when I was still
at the Wall Street Journal and we had
created an online video operation to to
do video directly over the top and the
story popped up one day and Gawker and
it's the wall street journal starting
this video operation in a typical old
media fashion they've hired 60 people to
do it and I at the time I think had nine
people working on this so i called the
reporter up and i said i got nine people
i don't know where you got the 60 number
he said oh that's great i'll go post
that right now and i said okay fine but
let's back up a second I've been sitting
here all day long you could have called
me i would have taken the call why
didn't you call me and and this reporter
said oh this is the way it works we put
up information and then when we get new
information we'll put that up to i'm
sure you're familiar with that that
sentiment so this is the kind of thing
that you're you're dealing with out
there and that's why I totally
sympathize with what you're saying you
see just crap come from nowhere and say
whoa what is that but you can't just
leave it there you have to go after it
and try and correct yeah and on these
things these little nuances matter in
terms of in terms of who's going to vote
one way or another and say you do need
to change it very quickly although in
fact because the capital market is as
sophisticated as it is the real crap the
real bloggers
rumours and the real chatroom rumors
don't have as big an impact on the vote
as you might think they do because the
financial institutions are pretty
sophisticated and they're going to rely
on more reliable sources of information
they think fortune is one of them and
they think fortune is one of them now
now one impact of fortune I mentioned
the impact on the board of directors of
the company a bad article in fortune
about the CEO or about the board that
carries a tremendous amount of weight in
the boardroom much more so than let's
say a blog post that says this is a
lousy border that what that CEO plays
too much golf but a bad article in
fortune carries a lot of weight in that
regard Steve let me push on a point that
Alan made earlier i think it was his
third point about the fundamental
asymmetry of the activist engagement and
I and here i'll add a pile on to Alan's
comment and then I'd be interested in
your response so I think part of it is
you know an activist may have a
particular view of a weakness or
potential potential new Avenue that
might be pursued by a company they may
be open about it but they may hold it
close to their best when they arrive on
the scene with a you know with a public
letter and a 13d filing the board can
often be caught flat-footed and not
really realized that this particular
issue was going to be was going to be
forthcoming or at least in anytime soon
you do here's one area where I fervently
believe that some some activist
shareholders are asymmetric not only are
they energetic and good looking and good
manages the press but in Bill Ackman's
what five hour conference call the other
day they clearly have way better bladder
control than I do because there was only
one bathroom break during the entire
during the entire call so so that those
are a lot of asymmetries right you can
sort of pounce you can sort of make your
case and already be a significant
shareholder what does asymmetries do you
see on the other direction right so I
would agree that there is an
symmetry I think the companies and I
believe this when I was at kirkland &
ellis companies have all the advantages
and and the activists do have some
problems one of the problems is that
there is a misperception that companies
are flat footed when they get that call
from the activist saying I'm filing a
13d tonight and you're going to read
about it in the newspaper tomorrow the
fact is that most significant companies
have investment banks that they have on
retainer for what they call activist
defense those activists defense firms
have an incredibly good ear to the to
the market and they have a pretty good
idea what's going on secondly a lot of
big companies use stock watch services I
have no idea how those stock watch
services work but I'm concerned that
they get him too much information and
they provide the information to the
company and so I don't think it's a
coincidence that when the activists in
fact files a 13d within a day the Board
of Directors has a prepared response
prepared by a very sophisticated
financial public relations firm and has
adopted a poison pill that it was poised
to adopt once this happened so I I don't
think the first place companies are
really caught flat-footed secondly I
think that the limitations that a lot of
companies claim they have as a result of
regulation FD which doesn't permit
people to make in general companies to
make in general selective disclosure I
think are really not as oppressive as
companies claim they are I think
companies a much freer to make
disclosure than they then
they claim they are third the company is
able to provide financial information
and forecasts that a lot of companies
are ready to provide and have worked
really hard to provide and have been
vetted by great investment banks and to
present that in a very effective way
fourth companies have the corporate
pocketbook which they use to hire
investigative firms and to come up with
whatever they can come up with on the
activist and I think in fact because
companies have the advantages that I'm
talking about now that the companies
have basically gotten smart and have and
have dropped the idea that what the
activists are doing is inherently evil
but they're saying gee is this a good
idea or is it not a good idea and
they're saying it objectively I think
we're going to see more situations where
the activists don't prevail I think
we're already seeing a lot of
settlements where the company is saying
to the activist okay rather than a proxy
contest where the most people you're
going to elect is is 32 this board why
don't we get together and choose an
independent director that we're both
happy with and we'll add to the board
and we'll settle so i think that the
market is getting more mature in this
area and i think one of the reasons is
that there is more of a balance between
the activists and the and the companies
and people have recognized having said
that it is true my boss bill ackman is a
brilliant young handsome wealthy guy and
he is very colorful and says things on
television that people remember so the
TV reporters keep wanting them on there
dan dan loeb is another colorful fellow
and carl icahn my god so that is an
advantage they have but you know some
corporate managers actually present
themselves reasonably well there let me
go ahead
I think the the other key thing that
Steve's raising is that you know we're
talking about the media aspects of this
which are obviously the things that
you've already seen once they've gone
you know nuclear or time started yelling
at each other you know what you don't
see is the level of engagement that goes
on often times before you get to that
point and I think you know in addition
to all these other you know kind of
through strategies that companies employ
you know we work a lot with them on how
to engage with these activist investors
before things become public and a lot of
times that can if you don't get to a
settlement or to an outcome that can be
helpful in terms of just the preparation
aspects of this so i think it's not i I
just it's not that you know Bill Ackman
does not spring is not always springing
this on people I think on a case-by-case
basis I think a lot of times there's a
lot there's a level of engagement I
think the way the companies deal with
that and the way the orchestrate that is
an important part of the defense so a
question that's a little bit more of a
guess slightly more of an academic II
question but I think it's relevant so
particularly in the current dispute and
Steve and I were talking about this
before the before the panel the the sort
of the current era involving activists
and presumed short-termism versus
long-term goals of directors one of the
one of the tools in the arsenal of just
about everyone in this debate is the
most recent academic study on whether
activism is good or bad for shareholders
and one of the things that you spend a
little bit of time with this literature
you're going to realize that if you have
enough time you can find an academic
study that's somewhat reputable that can
help bolster almost any position now
this is in part just because academics
just like everyone else or trying to
differentiate themselves this is in part
a challenge in trying to do the kind of
empirically oriented policy work in an
area where we don't have a lab where we
can have the control petri dish in the
treatment DP tradition and see how a
particular intervention works and so you
know you know that there's sort of an
non-stop and somewhat entertaining back
and forth between Marty
dilution babcock about which studies are
better for for for you know a particular
position which they each have committed
to one how do you think let me come with
outlet and work my way back down to
Steve huh how do you deal with a
landscape that now seems to be kind of
intermingled with with you know
empirical scholarship or policy reports
or research reports that purport to show
that that either aunt you know the
activism is either the best thing since
pimento loaf or or the Antichrist yeah
and look I think that goes back to the
second point I made which is reporters
don't have a lot of time to bit too
frankly to read academic studies I mean
I'm constantly amazed not just in this
area but in lots of areas how wide the
gulf between academic work and
journalistic work has grown the
conversation I mean the two people you
mentioned Lucien and Marty are pretty
are both pretty effective operators of
the media but there are many areas where
academic opinion and journalistic
opinion diverged greatly and there
doesn't seem to be much of a
conversation going on I don't quite know
how how to explain that I mean there's
been an effort to try and close the
something called the conversation are
you familiar with the conversation at
all which is an effort to try and take
academic studies and make them more if i
can say readable and and put them online
in a way that that more people see them
and they filter into the journalistic
conversation more but but so so i don't
think that's a huge thing because i
don't think there are many reporters
that have a lot of time to spend a lot
of time looking at the academic research
sad to say yeah it's in cal well i have
to confess i'm not sure how much time
our team spent looking at the egg and a
keen eye research either you know i
think that look here's sort of the the
piece i think they kind of got our
attention of late not an academic study
but Moody's has been following you know
Moody's puts out their court their
report on activism quarterly and they
just did the one that went up I think
through november or it came out in
november and what they said was that of
the there are 10 activists that account
for fifty percent of all the campaigns
against companies that that they rate
and and and i think what that what that
tells us is that it is to allen's point
around sort of the the profile of these
people i think one of the things that we
deal with with clients is that you have
this group of very powerful activist
investors that just their mere presence
kind of on your share register just
creates a lot of visibility and and and
it's not all of them but it's certainly
the top ones and so you know you need to
it's the fact that just the mere
presence of these people showing up
that's driving a lot of as media
coverage even in the absence of
arguments coming out from both sides
that i think is a very interesting
dynamic in terms of how we manage these
things maybe God's even so a couple of
years ago I went to a presentation by
Lucian bebb Chuck discussing his then
most recent paper which showed that
activism really benefited companies in
the long term and he concluded by saying
that he thinks that any lawyer who comes
in to represent a board of a company
it's facing an activist has an
obligation to tell the board that
activism benefits companies in the long
run on a general basis and I remember
thinking to myself I that's even though
my instinct is that Lucien is right
that's unbelievable nonsense because if
I ever said that to a board they would
laugh at me before they'd replace me and
and so I thought that what I did tell
boards was that if they wanted somebody
who was going to stand there and give
speeches saying how evil activism is I
was the wrong person because that's not
what I thought they should be thinking
about because each situation
stands on its own and that in fact is
one of the problems with the empirical
research that people have done I think I
actually trust the people of most of the
people who've done it some are sort of I
look like they're almost not academics
Marik but the academics who've done it
have done serious work and I think
they've tried to do it fairly but I just
think that most of the work is
unpersuasive to me and that's because
each situation stands by itself so you
go into a boardroom and if an activist
is proposing you just split up the
company and the problem as the activist
hasn't realized that it's going to
trigger ten billion dollars of debt that
issue isn't dealt with by some general
principles or by some empirical research
that's an issue where you have to sit
down with the activists and explain to
them what the problem is by the same
token if a board of directors has been
deferring the idea of splitting up the
company for a couple of years and is now
on its ninth study and third investment
bank and the activist is going to run a
campaign saying split up the company
it's worth more as two companies that it
is one maybe it's time to actually bite
the bullet and say should we do it or
should we not do it and and forget about
whether activism is generally good or
not one last question I want to open it
up to audience questions this is sort of
the turn the tables question so one of
the well no I'm going to turn the tables
on the entire debate so you know I guess
one of the one of the white elephant
prizes that comes along with the recent
success of shareholder activism in
getting board seats in unseating boards
is that those activists then they're in
control so Dan Loeb gotta seats on this
on the Sotheby's board and is now in
some damage control mode right because
the company is not you know not
performing particularly well at least
right now you know Bill Ackman spent a
lot of time you know discussing the the
position of Pershing Square and valiant
the other day too so to what extent is
that a is that different than the
the sort of the the ordinary messaging
point or the fact that one is all has
you sort of got there it's like the dog
that caught the bus so yeah exactly
exactly that does is there anything
different about the fact that the route
to being in that position was an
activist route that that makes it
different in kind let me start with cow
on this I don't know whether there's a
messaging point that's a little bit
different about that or not the routine
getting I'm well I mean I think one of
the things that I think that raises is
the extent to which you know people
think that you know companies dealing
with activists that the things that
they're doing they're doing because of
the presence of the act isn't because
because they're being pushed and you
know we've dealt with clients where
they're there in the middle of the
situation and the activist is not on the
board yet but but but could get there in
the somewhat near term and they they
really want to pull their horns in we
have one client I decided they wanted to
take their CEO completely off of any
media platform indefinitely because
every time they put the CEO on CNBC or
talk to a reporter they were getting
questions about the presence of the
activist and there was always this
intimation that the reason that they
were making certain decisions with the
company was was more because the
activist was there and the shares had
gone up over this period of time and so
they were they were in that situation
and I think what that raises I think
think leads to me is that you know you
have to be careful when you're in that
situation and it looks like you're doing
things because of the presence of the
activists just a couple of journalistic
observations I moderated a at fortune
has the most powerful women's conference
which has a lot of CEOs board directors
and I moderated an off-the-record lunch
with about 35 women who sat on fortune
500 boards of directors and was
surprised I can't tell the specific I
can tell one specific instance for
reasons I'll tell you in a minute but I
but I was surprised there were three
different people in that room
who talked about activists who they had
tried to keep off the board but once
they came on the board were incredibly
productive and useful and helpful the
one incident that was in that room that
I can talk about because meg whitman
herself talks about it quite openly is
HP and Ralph Whitworth no I don't know
if Ralph Whitworth is typical of the
genre generally but you know megs
approach to Ralph Whitworth was oh god
you know I'm going to do a meeting with
this guy and let's hope it's the last
time I ever have to see him instead he
ended up on her board and if you talked
to her today she would describe him as
one of the most valuable members of her
board and I think he's is he lead
independent director of one of the two
companies I don't know but she will she
credits him great she credits him with
having a very important and positive
role in the strategy of the company so
and there are other examples of that so
the the Fox seems to be a more helpful
Stewart's on the inside then went on the
outside one of the issues for the
activists is to what extent are they
going to associate themselves with the
company are they going to just be an
investor and on the board or are they
going to try to be a spokesperson for
the company and there are pluses and
minuses to that and the minuses were
demonstrated certainly for Pershing
Square when we made a big investment in
JC Penney bill Ackman went on the board
of JC penney the board of directors
which was I think 13 people and Bill was
one of them selected AC a new CEO for
the company bill was all over the media
taking some credit for that higher the
higher turned out to be a very
unfortunate hire it didn't work and
bill ended up getting a disproportionate
share of the blame i believe for that
unwise higher but that's one of the
issues that the activist has to face to
what extent are they going to take
credit for successes because if you do
that you're going to get the blame for
the losses too all right well speaking
of turning the tables let me turn the
table on the audience we have a few more
minutes for Q&A and I think Marcel do we
have microphones that are going around
excellent so if you have a question
please feel free to raise it identify
yourself and we can have it up here for
the board yes sir
retro lado a little bit off-topic but
directly related to the role of the
corporation the University and
journalism and Ron is now suing Columbia
University over an academic study that
was done talking about their role in
early analysis of climate change
something which potentially could impact
investors in the way they view the
long-term viability and business
strategy of the company suing an
academic institution for doing you know
valuable you know academic research you
can take it for whether it's worth seems
to be sort of a nexus that that
pressures the role of the university and
frankly what this institute is trying to
do right here so I'm not sure who that
should go to a Vallon if as a journalist
if you've got some view on the role of
corporations and academia and media does
not have a chance for you well I don't
know if you're aware but joke run fest
who's the professor at Stanford Law
School and Dan Gallagher who's now a
former commissioner have been urging
that Harvard Law School and professor
behb Chuck be indicted for having
committed securities law violated that
was going to be my second question and
and since I went to Yale Law School I
don't find that incredibly obnoxious but
but frankly the the idea of suing
academic institutions under the
circumstances that I've mentioned and
the one that you mentioned seems
somewhat preposterous but it we may see
more of it if it gets there are examples
of successful suits of that nature
not the guy we're of any I there have
been many filed over the years so you're
not immune from libel and slander just
because you're publishing an academic
study but but certainly to the extent
that the the referee process is used the
data that are used or made publicly
available it's very hard to put that
case to put that kind of a case forward
that doesn't mean that it would be
impossible to go for come but there's
also no damages because no one ever
reads these studies so I'll try not to
have that hurt my hurt my feelings I
mean one thing is very interesting about
the about the Grund fest you know
charges it is that a this seems to be an
odd venue to take an academic debate
right to actually move what had been a
pretty / fervid it may be a little bit
too frothy academic debate and actually
turn it into a plea for for an
indictment that's just seem kind of odd
to me quite frankly was also odd that a
sitting SEC Commissioner was a co-author
it seems it seems a little bit seems a
little bit strange as well I on the
Exxon example I take some comfort from
the fact that that company treats
academics the same way it treats
journalists any other questions all
right well I want to please join me in
thanking our panelists for for the
discussion
you